when you did saturday night live that
was a big deal to you because i read
this thing about how your father when he
wanted to keep you busy if he was having
a party or something he'd throw you in
front of the tv and say watch saturday
night live so that must have been
another surreal moment doing saturday
night live what three four times or
something you did it
i hosted it three times and i've been a
guest on it on multiple occasions you
know walk on or what have you you know
do you feel totally comfortable doing
that kind of thing live because i would
think for an actor it is a little
different the live aspect and then all
of a sudden kind of playing jon hamm's
you know yeah i remember the first time
i did it
and this was
pretty famously the episode that amy
poehler
uh had had a baby during uh and she
couldn't be
on the show
so we had to scramble at the last minute
and change the thing and coldplay had to
do another song and
so it was the the live aspect of it was
very real
and i got to the to 8h at whatever two
o'clock in the afternoon for the show
and you're getting ready and there and
you knock on the door uh amy's having
her baby so the we're losing this sketch
and this is not a cold place gonna do
and then we're gonna change basically
we're gonna change the whole show
so it's like oh uh okay uh in six hours
right okay great yeah um what where do i
need to go
like we're gonna get you don't worry
about it and that's the amazing part of
that show is that everyone's like
okay yes don't worry about it meanwhile
but you're not part of that and so
you're coming from an actor's point of
view where you're prepared i remember
standing behind like getting ready to go
for dress rehearsal at eight o'clock
it's dress rehearsal and the band's
playing and it's it's basically the the
show it's just not
on the air
and
i'm standing behind the thing getting
ready to go through the door and the
band is playing you can't hear anything
but people don't realize is that
how small the the
stage is that snl is on you think it's
this huge
place because it's got weekend update
that must be its own wing and then and
then the other things are in their own
thing it's all in one thing they just
keep moving stuff around it's like
tetris
so i remember
being
utterly terrified waiting for for my cue
to go on
and the band is playing and i can i can
feel the bass drum the kick drum
because it's literally
six inches away from me just separated
by a you know a thin
piece of plywood
and the stage manager is screaming
you know and you know the don pardo's
reading your name
and i i don't know what happened but i
realized in that moment i was like oh
oh
this is a roller coaster
i just have to not fall out of the
roller coaster and i'll be fine
i'll hold on to the bar i'll enjoy and i
was like i'll just enjoy the ride
this is what it's supposed to be it's
supposed to be
and i remember i was kind of having this
out of body moment behind the thing and
and jenna rossitano who's the the stage
manager had to push me out the door
because i had missed my queue i was
musing about how i figured it out
get out go
and i go out and it's you know and then
and then the rest is is history i had
the best time that was like what was the
cast that i was closest with but those
guys hate her and wig and polar even
though she wasn't there maya and brad
and i just remember like having the best
time and i was like oh right yeah enjoy
this enjoy it enjoy the insanity enjoy
the chaos
what an incredible epiphany to have as
you're walking in 30 seconds 30 seconds
because if you didn't have that you
would have been miserable and uptight
and nervous yeah and but i would think
that whole idea of reading cue cards and
not being able to look at the person
you're talking to it's just such a
strange experience somebody told me i
think it was jason bateman i was like
what do i do how do i'm terrified i'm
gonna go in there and i'm gonna i'm
gonna suck and it's gonna he goes no no
just go
and be their guest
you're their guest like you're going to
their home
you know be polite be their guest
they've been doing this for 40 some odd
years they know how to do it don't tell
them
you're not going to tell them anything
that they don't know
and and in fact i think the people that
maybe don't have the best reputations on
that have been there have have tried to
let me i'll rework the show
you're not going to rework
lauren's anything he's got it on lock he
knows what's up